[Musique]
vous êtes à l'intérieur d'une image
ancienne représentant l'illustre port
d'Amsterdam mais faites bien
attention dans un instant le rêve après
une transition obligatoire parmi les
automates va vous déverser dans le
réel diabolisme
insidieux regardez
bien
[Musique]
et voilà vous avez certainement compris
le procédé vous secouez doucement une
estampe il en tombe des marionnettes qui
bâtissent une ville
où il n'y a plus qu'à mettre des
Hollandais c'est simple comme un compte
de
[Musique]
feu la Hollande s'est fait avec de la
soudure et de
l'énergie vous posez un Hollandais sur
l'eau il flotte 10 ans après il fait de
la bicyclette au même endroit il a sous
les pieds de la bonne terre bien grasse
qui n'y est pas venue toute seule mais
par l'effet de l'un des déploiements de
courage et d'obstination les plus
extraordinaires de tous les
temps mise à flot par la mer le
Hollandais s'est fait amiral et
marchand de la fortune acquise dans le
commerce
maritime il a fait ce que font les marin
qui rentre chez eux il l'a converti en
terre avec cette différence
toutefois que cette terre n'existait pas
et qu'il lui a fallu l'inventer la
fabriquer avec des blocs et du ciment de
la ferraille et du
rocher un homme de lettre du pays a
écrit qu'Amsterdam était la ville la
plus poétique
d'Europe toutes les villesant soit peu
pourvu d'histoire sont poétiqu surtout
lorsqu'elles sont couchées sur les EAU
mais toutes ne versifi pas de la même
façon les unes s'expriment en
alexandrin d'autres se raconent en ver
libre dans le fracas des P mécaniques le
crachement de la soudure à l'arc la
déglutition des trémis et le tonner des
péniches qui lâchent leur cargaison de
caillou le poème d'Amsterdam commence
comme le fameux disti d'Arthur
rau mangeons l'air le r les charbons le
[Musique]
fer tel est le menu du Hollandais qui
fait passenser tout ça avec un grand
bouillon d'eau
salée
mais n'exagérons rien ils ne mangent pas
que
cela et si chargé de travaux qu'il soit
la précautionneuse lenteur des
transports maritimes lui laisse tout de
même du temps deant en lui pour fumer la
pipe et tout le monde sait s'il a du bon
tabat dans sa tabatière en se laissant
glisser sur le grand canal
entre les belles tranches de ces maisons
pur sucre et
cacao coupés au couteau à
beurre aligné comme sur l'étagère d'une
épicerie
géante et dans lesquelles on se dit
qu'il ne peut rien arriver que de
doucement pacifique et quotidien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce combat permanent qui ne peut pas
s'arrêter sans que l'eau monte ou que la
ville baisse fait d'Amsterdam une ville
qui rajunit tous les jours entre ces
vieilles maisons qui rappelle Vermer
l'admirable et ces constructions
nouvelles qui pourrai être signé
mondriillant si les peintres avaient une
palette de ciment
[Musique]
armé
pour le reste et à cela prê que l'on y
voit couramment ceci vous sera à montrer
dans un instant des jeunes filles gobé
des poissons crus qui les environne d'un
agréable parfum de haute mer il est bien
évident qu'Amsterdam est aussi une ville
comme les
autres avec des
[Musique]
cafés des gens à
table des rues qui mèent à d'autres rues
qui se jettent dans la
[Musique]
mer